[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 rosa pérez más de 2 ya está
conmigo en el estudio rosa vamos abrir
entonces esta revista de prensa con las
reacciones mediáticas a esta cumbre de
las américas que arranca hoy 6 de junio
en la ciudad de los ángeles en eeuu y
empezamos con la opinión del 'washington
post' buenos días raúl exactamente no y
es que el washington post dice by den no
puede unir el hemisferio occidental
porque se cae en pedazos bueno esta es
una tribuna de opinión o de este medio
de comunicación estadounidense que como
la prensa internacional y sobre todo la
del continente americano se fija más que
en los temas que hay que abordar en esta
cumbre como serían cambio climático o
migración o inflación pues en las
ausencias a esta cita no y es que bueno
recordemos que por exclusión sobre todo
una decisión tomada por eeuu pero más en
general por la organización de estados
americanos no han sido invitados no a
esta importante cumbre ni el presidente
ha cubano díaz canel ni el a venezolano
nicolás maduro ni tampoco el
nicaragüense daniel ortega
en protesta a estas exclusiones tampoco
asistirá el presidente mexicano lópez
obrador bien el washington post dice que
bardem hace bien en no invitar a los
tiranos de la región y dice que las
discrepancias sobre cómo abordar las
dictaduras latinoamericanos ponen de
relieve los problemas de esta región
este medio mira también con cierta
nostalgia la primera cumbre de las
américas que tuvo también lugar en eeuu
en ese caso en miami en
1994 y lamenta un poco los cambios que
ha habido desde entonces es que
recordemos que ese momento era justo
pues tras el fin de la guerra fría en
una situación en geopolítica que muchos
consideraban como el fin de la historia
no el triunfo digamos del capitalismo
estadounidense sobre el resto del mundo
y lamenta los cambios que ha habido pues
en el mundo político sobre todo en el
continente americano desde entonces dice
que américa latina ha elegido populistas
como hablo o bolsonaro se olvida eso sí
de citar a trump y dice que incluso
colombia un aliado tradicionalmente
estable de la región no está inmune de
posibles populismos después frente a
estas elecciones no una comparativa un
poco deshonesta así es rosa mágico con
la administración estadounidense es el
de los ángeles time y titulada by quien
trata evitar el fracaso en la cumbre de
las américas si porque si bien el
'washington post' defiende que eeuu debe
reforzar su influencia sobre la región
para limitar digamos la influencia china
y rusa aquí en américa latina 'los
ángeles times' dice que eeuu no debería
en esta cumbre presentar una visión
grandiosa del hemisferio sino mostrar
sensibilidad hacia tres puntos no
digamos escuchar a la región en términos
de por qué se ha decidido acercar a
rusia o china o la preocupación no de
américa latina por la desigualdad y
también comprender la tradicional
desconfianza regional hacia eeuu dicen
más que dar discursos eeuu debería
escuchar si también vamos ahora con el
universal de venezuela que citan las
palabras nicolás maduró dice alberto
fernández era la voz de venezuela en la
cumbre de las américas rosa exacto y es
que pues como decíamos el presidente
venezolano ha sido excluido de esta
cumbre pero digamos que llegó a un
acuerdo con su homólogo argentino
alberto fernández quien hace un nicolás
maduro va a llevar pues la voz de
venezuela como decías a esta cumbre que
el propio presidente pues venezolano
citó como pues a la cumbre de la
protesta contra el imperialismo
estadounidense y bueno si bien a raúl en
esta cumbre como decíamos hay que
abordar temas claves para la región pues
digamos que tanto venezuela como cuba
como nicaragua son países claves no que
después también tienen muchas cosas que
decir sobre todo pues es importante su
papel en cuestiones tan importantes como
la migración por ejemplo en el
continente claro rosa ahora vamos
cambiando de tema con los grandes temas
que ocupan las portadas los periódicos
en reino unido es el lunes exacto porque
las portadas del reino unido- se dividen
por un lado en el cierre de este jubileo
de platino de la reina isabel segunda y
digamos todos los de la estabilidad y la
unidad que supuestamente aporta la
monarquía pues británica al reino unido-
y estas digamos celebraciones de la
monarquía contrastan con otro tema de
actualidad total en el reino unido- y es
que posiblemente podemos ver pues las
últimas horas de boris johnson como
primer ministro del reino unido- y vemos
que en el momento de imprimir las
rotativas todavía no estaba cierto que
se iba a celebrar esta pues emoción de
confianza el primer ministro británico
hoy mismo pero finalmente como nos decía
luisa desde londres es algo que va a
acabar pasando a partir de hoy a las 6
de la tarde y precisamente el medio y
destaca que diputados conservadores
acusan al gobierno de chantaje para
intentar evitar esta moción de censura